JoJosée Legault, Michel C. Auger
AlAlec Castonguay, bonsior.
- - (ensemble) : Bonsoir.
JeJe vais faire un tour de table
ulultrarapide avant de vous faie
écécouter les premiers extraits.
JeJe vous demande, c'est présent
quque je fais ça. Mais oui ou n,
avavait-il le choix de faire ce
ququ'il a fait aujourd'hui puisn
vava expliquer en moult détails
totout ça.
- - Je dirais oui, mais..
- - avait-il le choix?
- - Non, pas quand lui-même avoa
ququ'on allait dans le mur.
- - Non.
- - Je vous faire entendre
MoMonsieur Legault d'abord et
enensuite Monsieur Dubé qui
exexplique effectivement que ce
dedevenaient impossible comme
éqéquation.
- - Je pense que quand on regare
lala balance des inconvénients,
c'c'était la décision responsabe
àà prendre. Maintenant, je vais
lalaisser Christian expliquer
lele fond.
- - Est-ce que c'est un échec,
MoMonsieur le premier ministre?
EsEst-ce que c'est un échec
popour vous?
- - C'est la balance
dedes inconvénients.
IlIl n'y a rien de parfait.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - Je crois que si on continue
cocomme ça, on va foncer dans
unun mur. Et comme ministre
dede la Santé, avec mon équipe,
j'j'ai la responsabilité de
prprotéger le réseau de la santé
dede tous les Québécois, mais
auaussi de protéger notre résea.
EtEt là, le risque en ce moment,
ilil est trop élevé. Et ça serat
irirresponsable de jouer aux dés
avavec la santé des Québécois.
- - Je vous donne quelques
exexemples puis après c'est a vs
lala parole. En termes d'impact,
c'c'est la sous-ministre qui avt
unune énumération sur 600 lits
fefermés, de plus c'est en
cocontinué avec 22 000 personnes
dede moins dans le réseau. 115
sasalles d'opération au total de
fefermés. On aurait ajouté 30
dodonc. Réduction de service?
DPDPJ, soit le CHSLD. Tout y est
papassé. Moins de tout pour tout
lele monde. Josée, ce qui est
ététonnant, c'est que le discous
enen une nuit Assange
drdramatiquement.
- - C'est ça mon mail. Je dis qe
lele maître avait le choix, je e
babase ce qu'il a dit lui-même
hihier. Jusqu'à hier, la date
bubutoir était le 15 octobre. Et
llà, il s'est passé quelque choe
enentre hier et aujourd'hui,
dodoucement mais, je pense que a
vava être le projet livre, qu'e-
cece c'était pas dans les 24
heheures?
jeje pardonnerai beaucoup sans e
sasavoir. C'est quand même un
rerevirement du tout au tout. Ca
ététend dit, je ne doute pas dea
bobonne foi du ministre dans ce
dodossier. Je n'ai pas
l'l'impression qu'il a pris cete
dédécision de gaieté de coeur. e
pepense aussi qu'il croit
sisincèrement que d'ici un mois,
ilil va pouvoir mettre en place
cecertaine nombre de mesures qul
fafait qui pourrait imposer la
ststation le 15 novembre, mais
c'c'est un pari risqué.
- - Oui, parce que une fois qu'n
bobouge une fois une date n'est
plplus immuable.
- - Vous savez, on parlait de s.
QuQuand tes ulultimatums comme ,
ilil n'y a plus de retour de
crcroissance. Ça ne marche pas,a
prprochaine fois ce ne marche ps
dudu tout. Est-ce qu'il est
cacapable de convaincre 6000
pepersonnes qui ont déjà une do,
prprobablement complet convaince
d'd'aller chercher la deuxième,
dadans les autres, ils veulent e
lala santé, s'ils ne l'ont pas
fafait, malgré toute la
pepersuasion, je pense que le
gogouvernement, ça montre que le
réréseau et a la corde et que ls
reressources ne sont pas là.
C'C'est un groupe bien,
reretour sur la réalité est
didifficile le réseau est vraimt
mamal en ; même cette quatrième
vavague moins bien que dans
d'd'autres provinces.
- - Le premier ministre et
ChChristian Dubé ministre de la
sasanté en fait un pari a la fin
dudu mois d'août il y avait
susuffisamment de pression se
trtravers de la santé hésitant,
rérécalcitrants pour qu'à la mi-
ococtobre en soit capable de
memettre une date butoir ! Buto.
CeCe pari a été perdu. Christian
DuDubé a avoué avoir perdu son
papari, ne pas être comme ça mas
cece qui s'est produit, devait
totout un réseau de poussée de a
sasanté du soulagement est très
heheureux de reconnaître que le
miministre avait perdu son pari.
HiHier soir, lorsque la dernière
réréunion entre le PDG des CISSS
etet des CIUSSS... on va y arrir
vovous aller devoir augmenter de
mamanière spectaculaire les heus
enen plus de la protection déjàa
bobout de souffle. Il essence dà
ququatre de la santé parce que
sosoit épuisé, par conductance
coconductance supplémentaire.
SiSi vous augmentez le temps
susupplémentaire, vous brûlez
vovotre personnel, ce convaincre
acactuellement ne vont pas
rerevenir. P encore avec ce
didilemme. De gaieté de coeur qe
lele ministre a fait ce choix. e
pepense qu'il sait très bien
popolitiquement il y a un coup a
çaça. On est dubitatif sur ça va
prprofiter dans les prochains
momois. Mais il n'avait pas le
chchoix. Les bris de service
auauraient été trop nombreux
prpression se de la santé aurait
étété trop intense.
- - Et explique, il le dit en
coconférence de presse, je pouvs
enentendre l'autre extrait en
didisant que la seule façon de
prprendre ce virage des donnéese
gagaz vers le TSO, le
paparlementaire obligatoire et a
auaurait pu de ce que je veux
fafaire.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - Si on fait le plan avec
1414 000 personnes, je suis oblé
dede continuer à faire du 0-0-7
etet du temps supplémentaire
obobligatoire. Et moi, c'est ça
ququi m'a donné le coup de grâce
hihier soir. Je ne peux pas
dedemander aux PDG de trouver
dedes solutions parce qu'on enle
1414 000 personnes, puis en même
tetemps, dire au réseau :
écécoutez, faites-nous confianc,
onon va changer les conditions.
- - C'est ça qui a donné le coup
dede grâce a son plan. Je vous
momontre de ses prêtres
imimportants. On dit beaucoup de
chchiffres. Ce n'est pas
cocompliqué. Le 26 août, alors
ququ'on commençait, on savait qe
çaça arrive le 15, sa lettre
anannoncée début septembre, les3
4 461 personnes de la santé non
vavaccinés. Le pari entre
guguillemets perdus quand même
réréussis a coupé de moitié ce
grgroupe de noms vaccinés avec
242446. Là, le pari qu'il fait,e
vovous donne un des premiers
exextraits 22 000, le 15 novemb,
dedeviennent 8000 ou 10 000.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - Nous vous tendrons la main
etet nous espérons sincèrement
quque vous allez la saisir.
S'S'il vous plaît, faites-le
d'd'abord pour vous,
popour vos proches; sinon,
fafaites-le pour vos collègues
ququi ont besoin de vous.
OnOn a tous le droit de changer
d'd'idée quand on le fait pour
leles bonnes raisons.
- - José, c'est presque une
susupplication.
- - Oui, mais ce n'est pas la
prpremière fois qu'on entend. Il
fafaut savoir que dans les 14 00
nonon vaccinés du tout, qui n'ot
papas une première dose, écoute,
c'c'est malgré la date du 15
ococtobre. Qui avait l'air de
tetenir précieusement. C'est por
çaça que la nôtre se sont faits
vavacciner, c'est quand même 14
00000 personnes très
rérécalcitrantes. On ne parle ps
d'd'hésitants. Les étangs sont
fafaits vacciner où sont allés
chchercher une première dose. Ce
nene sont pas toutes des
ininfirmières non plus. Je veux
bibien le changement de culture,
popour éviter le travail
susupplémentaire obligatoire,
paparfait. Encore une fois, ce e
sosont pas toutes des infirmièrs
llà-dedans. Les techniciens de
lalaboratoire, mais il y a auss,
jeje pense que soupçonner beaucp
dede préposé aux bénéficiaires.
J'J'ai bien écouté le. De press,
leles ministres relèvent venaiet
sosouvent ses milieux de vie, ls
CHCHSLD, les ressources média, n
paparle de qui?
onon parle de préposé aux
bébénéficiaires. On était dans s
4 4 % manquants de vaccinés. Le
sysystème, on nous dit il y a 9%
dede vaccinés. Est très clair l-
dedessus. C'est dispersé de
mamanière très inégale. Alors,
dadans des CHSLD beaucoup plus e
4 4 % des préposés qui sont non
vavaccinés.
IlIl a même donné des exemples
popouvait être la moitié.
- - Oui, la moitié et qu'on allt
dedevoir fermer des ressources
inintermédiaires. Je reprends ma
ququestion, on savait ça les
ququatre jours.
- - C'est ça. J'ai hâte au
prprochain livre d'Alex 24 heurs
paparce que moi vraiment j'y pes
momon latin. Je reviens là-desss
paparce que c'est un échec aussi
dudu système qui ne date pas de
MoMonsieur Dubé mais d'avant. Iy
a a un problème de formation, iy
a a un problème d'éducation dans
leles préposé aux bénéficiaires
ququi font un travail
exextraordinaire. Mais quand mê,
bebeaucoup sont sous-payés,
bebeaucoup sont peu formés,
susurtout dans le réseau privé.n
paparle des ressources
inintermédiaires, c'est de ça dt
onon parle. Les gens qui
trtravaillent dans les milieux e
sasavent. C'est un secret de
popolichinelle. Le blocage ainsi
unun certain nombre de préposés
auaux bénéficiaires ou le
didialogue, la conduction ne pae
papas. Ce que nous dit pour
l'l'avenir, je pense que le
miministre doit s'en douter, ce
ququi va falloir donner une
foformation, une rémunération ds
coconditions meilleures, mais
l'l'information aussi qu'il doit
êêtre plus solide, une vraie
foformation préposée aux
bébénéficiaires pour que ces
réréflexes, qui sont basés sur s
totoutes sortes de raisons,
pupuissent disparaître du systè.
PaParce qu'ils vont mettre la ve
lala sécurité dans une personne
exextrêmement vulnérable.
- - Oui, tout à fait. Vous dîtes
dadans les ressources
inintermédiaires dans les CHSLD,
c'c'est vrai que la mise en a
bebeaucoup parlé mais elle a dit
ququ'il allait y avoir 600 lits
leles centres hospitaliers
réréguliers de fermer. 600 lits,
11115 salles d'opération, on
alallait ajouter 35 fermer 30
auautres salles d'opération. Mas
MiMichel, c'est comme si les non
vavaccinés avaient, passez-moi
l'l'expression, caller le bluffu
miministre. Parfait, nous on ne
bobouge pas.
- - Le vraiment pas ce qu'est-ce
ququ'une veux pas faire qui estn
ttête lapalissade du village
gagaulois. On arrive a ceux qui
ququoi qu'on dise, quoi qu'on
papasse ne se feront pas vaccin.
IlIl y a un certain nombre de
prpréposés, d'établir aussi, no,
jeje ne veux pas me faire
vavacciner, mettez-moi dehors si
vovous voulez. Il faut arriver a
cicirconscrire un peu de façon
plplus précise ce nombre.
FaFaire des plans en conséquenc.
CÇa, ça moi qui s'en viens.
- - C'est intéressant ce que vos
ddîtes. C'est moi qui s'en viens
AlAlec. Déveine 2000, le nombre
d'd'irréductibles qui ne changea
papas d'avis et avec cela il fat
alalors faire sans parce que sin
leles investigations dans le
réréseau.
- - On n'est pas 22 000 parts ds
leles 22 000 il y a sept ou 8000
ququi ont déjà leur prpremière .
LeLes logiques voulant qu'ilss
iriront chercher la deuxième do.
LeLes mesures qui viennent
d'd'arriver ce tableau ont porté
frfruit. Le fait que les ordres
prprofessionnels vont suspendree
ththème de pratique sur les
ininfirmières, les infirmières
auauxiliaires, les rappellent, s
phpharmaciens. Sa, a été annoncé
lulundi. Des desgens pensait que
çaça les pouvoir contourner le
tetemps que ça durerait. Ça va
dudurer de trois semaines et ils
vovont me rappeler. Sérieusement
dede pratique, ne pourront pas
cocoup de couteau dans ces
enendroits notre mesure qu'on
esespère que ça va porter ses
frfruits, c'est le fait que
jujusqu'à présent, on devait sur
trtrois tests de dépistage par
sesemaine pour le personnel de a
sasanté qui est en contact avec
dedes patients, ça en valait ANA
totous les travers de la santé,
ququ'il soit public, au privé sr
lele plancher des vaches. Il
fafaudra être testé trois fois r
sesemaine ne trouveront pas ça
agagréable. Il est déjà parti
sosoumis a ça. Ce sera suffisant
popour 14 001 zéro?
lala réponse est non. C'est
imimpossible. Apprenez on ne se
rerend pas vacciné Elena qui
seseront effectivement retranchs
dadans leur position.
OnOn peut le gérer, l'événemente
didit peut-être que si on a de
404000 ou 5000 t des plans de
cocontingence qui a de l'allure.
- - Cette annonce des ordres
prprofessionnels de suspendre ls
pepermis est reportée elle aussi
mamaintenant au 15 novembre. Et
elelle se matérialisera jamais i
auau 15 novembre il n'y a pas de
dédécrets de la vaccination
obobligatoire. Donc, il y a ence
unun jeu qui se fait. Et pour ls
tetests de dépistage, je
sosoumettrai que dans les petits
mimilieux de vie, comme les
reressources intermédiaires, moi
j'j'ai bien hâte de voir et quia
adadministrer ces tests de
dédépistage trois fois par semae
etet qui va en rendre compte. Pr
lele moment, mon côté Thomas
reressort.
- - C'est intéressant. Ce n'est
papas dans les petits milieux de
vivie intermédiaire justement
prprécisément où on aura pas le
chchoix que de dire détestent
réréguliers, trois fois semaine,
çaça va être ça votre vaccinati.
PaParce que sinon, on ne peut ps
fefermer le centre. Est-ce
n'n'arrivera pas là, Michel?
- - va probablement arriver là l
nene faut pas oublier que ça, ça
prprend des ressources. Faire
papasser le test de ministries r
elelle, par le suivi, ça prend s
reressources. A un moment donné,
vovous donnez quelque chose en
réréalité en termes de gens sure
plplancher?
s's'il y a trop, non. C'est une
sosolution, ce n'est pas
nénécessairement la solution.
- - Alors je vous pose la questn
enen terminant, comme il reste e
tetemps. Il reste deux minutes.
EsEst-ce que c'était alors, come
tetenu de ce qu'on dit, de son
ananalyse, c'était une erreur qe
d'd'imposer la vaccination
obobligatoire pour tout le mond?
dede la santé.
- - Non, c'est une nécessité
esespère que ce sera fait le 15
nonovembre au plus tard.
- - Non, ce n'était pas une
ererreur.
- - Va finir par être gérable.
- - J'espère. Mon on ne peut pas
didire ça.
- - Alec, on est allé trop loinn
n'n'avait pas le choix?
- - je pense n'haver pas le cho,
enen même temps, la réponse plus
dodonc que non je pense n'haver
papas le choix, je pense qu'ils
auauront été au plus loin qu'il
popouvait parce qu'ils ont quand
mmême eu un certain nombre de
pepersonnes qui se sont pliées
l'exercice. Je pense qu'il pense
vrvraiment être capable au 15
ococtobre de pouvoir gérer le
nonombre de personnels le réseau
esest trop mal an. Pour ça et
pepeut-être que ça, on a mal
cacalculé.
- - Est-ce que le ministre Dubé,
paparce que linconnu, il a eu ue
gegestion qui a été reconnue par
totous, elle ne s'est pas sentie
dadans ce dossier, plus fort en
didisant on va être capable,
susuivez-moi. Être capable dansa
- - forêt les choses plus
didifficiles que d'autres. Oui,
mamais ça sa qualité principale.
VoVoudrais pas que la perte. Mo,
jeje suis persuadé qu'il va tout
esessayer dans le mois qui s'en
vivient, m mais il faut le fair.
AlAlors qu'il fasse.
- - Michel. Tu nous as surpris
totout à l'heure et en même tem,
lala sous-ministre faisait la
liliste, je disais, oublie, dans
lele fond, comment peut-on ajour
unune goutte de pression en ce
réréseau qui est déjà saturé?
- - Et s'il veut être pris au
sesegment ministre de la santé,
ququi dit moi attend, temps
susupplémentaire obligatoire je
vavais l'abolir, ne peut pas die
exexcusez-nous, c'est la crise a
vovous en demander encore plus.
CÇa, ne pouvait pas elle a été
trtrès claire